[Musica]
era la 11 marzo del 2020 quando lo ms
dichiarava che la cover 19 era da
considerarsi a tutti gli effetti una
pandemia
ricordo come fino a pochi giorni prima
molti di noi eravamo piuttosto scettici
riguardo alle potenzialità di questo
nuovo coronavirus anche sulla base il
parere degli esperti
eppure in quel giorno in cui l'undici
marzo 2020
mi sono chiesto ma se realmente la
nostra specie di homo sapiens dovessero
affrontare una pandemia dovessero far
fronte a una crisi dal punto di vista
sanitario ha una diffusione enorme di
contagi saremmo davvero in grado di
pianificare gli interventi in maniera
efficace
beh a quell'epoca era piuttosto
difficile rispondere a questa domanda
eppure ho incominciato a chiedermi
appunto che cosa fosse questa infezione
ma cosa rappresentasse non tanto per la
nostra specie ma anche per le altre
specie
infatti noi umani non siamo sicuramente
gli unici animali l'unica specie che
deve far fronte a sfide così dure come
quella di una pandemia
e così partendo dalla mia formazione
accademica dalle mie varie esperienze un
cominciando appunto a riflettere sul
fatto che veramente esistono tantissimi
casi in natura di comportamenti di
controllo delle infezioni comportamenti
igienici ad esempio potremmo citare il
caso degli uccelli
alcune di queste specie come i
passeriformi o gli storni utilizzano un
comportamento molto
potrei dire bizzarro che è la
fumigazione molto simile a quello che
facciamo noi in casa con gli incensi
ovvero applicano delle erbe aromatiche
in alcuni casi sono anche dei mozziconi
di sigaretta all'interno del nido
lo scopo è come lo di disinfettarlo di
renderlo appunto più igienizzato per
ridurre la possibilità di insorgenza di
malattie quindi assolutamente simile a
quello che facciamo noi magari con un
incenso nelle nostre case e poi passando
invece al mondo dei mammiferi
un vero maestro dell'igiene il tasso il
tasso un abitante notturno nei nostri
boschi e vive in delle tane solitamente
rivestite con muschi fogli e arbusti
soprattutto nei mesi invernali
il tasso solito cambiare questo
rivestimento lo espone al sole e appunto
sostituisce il fogliame questo perché
perché riduce la possibilità della
proliferazione di parassiti o eventuali
patogeni e poi abbiamo alcuni casi di
cosmesi quindi cura del corpo è
l'esempio dei cebi dai cornetti queste
scimmie che arrivano dal sud america che
utilizzano una sorta di spray
antizanzare sfruttano le sostanze
urticanti e prodotte dai mille piedi
questo artropode per appunto allontanare
le zanzare evitare punture e poi abbiamo
il caso invece degli elefanti africani
elefanti che utilizzano l'argilla se la
cospargano sul derma per ridurre la
possibilità di scottature che
chiaramente potrebbero poi compromettere
il loro sistema immunitario e quindi
aumentare il rischio di malattie
infettive e quindi di fronte a tutto
questo scenario potremmo chiederci cosa
c'entra questo con il rapporto che noi
abbiamo ad esempio in questa attuale
pandemia
beh se ci sforzassimo di osservare il
mondo animale ancora più da vicino ci
accorgeremmo che molti dei comportamenti
che stiamo mettendo in atto in questi
mesi sono del tutto simili se non
identici a quelli che vengono messi in
atto dalle altre specie animali e quindi
sempre parlando di mammiferi potremmo
citare i nostri cugini gli scimpanzé
infatti secondo le osservazioni fatte
dall etologa britannica jane goodall e
poi confermate più recentemente da studi
scientifici quando all'interno del
gruppo uno scimpanzé manifesta chi ha i
sintomi di una malattia infettiva viene
allontanato anche con una certa violenza
fin quando non si riesce a stabilire
a quel punto può di nuovo essere
riammesso nel gruppo e quindi in questo
caso vediamo come il bene comune il bene
del gruppo venga ben prima rispetto agli
interessi del singolo individuo ed è un
caso assolutamente è molto simile a
quello che potremmo definire 40 era o
distanziamento sociale per noi umani e
poi passiamo invece a un mondo
completamente diverso a quello degli
insetti
infatti le api domestiche sono le vere
inventrici del già disinfettante
infatti all'interno dell'alveare
troviamo la propoli è una sostanza che
viene elaborata dalle api proprio a
partire da una resina vegetale e viene
utilizzata con uno scopo ben preciso
quello di ridurre la possibilità di
contagi all'interno dell'alveare fra i
singoli individui e anche di in qualche
modo come un cemento disinfettante per
sigillare le varie celle e quindi
rendere ancora più sicuro l'alveare
perché vicino le api perché in realtà
gli insetti sociali come formiche o
termiti sono in realtà un vero esempio
per noi umani perché molti dei
comportamenti che mettono in atto dal
punto di vista la coordinazione come
super organismo sono in realtà dei
comportamenti veramente efficaci e che
dovrebbero farci riflettere visto che
anche noi e homo sapiens sannio siamo
una specie sociale ma abbiamo grosse
difficoltà a coordinarci ed allearci
verso un nemico comune e quindi a questo
punto sarebbe lecito chiederci ma
possiamo davvero imparare qualcosa di
animali rispetto al tema dell'immunità
dell'igiene o del controllo delle
infezioni
molti studi scientifici ci dicono come
negli ultimi anni ci sia una grande
aumento delle cosiddette malattie
emergenti queste nuove infezioni causate
da uno spill over quindi un salto di
specie e nonostante la nostra specie
homo sapiens abbiano tutto affrontare in
un passato più remoto
delle pandemie molto gravi ad esempio
come la peste come l'influenza spagnola
o in tempi più recenti virus devastanti
come la cai v e le bola nonostante
questo c'è da dire che la copy 19 ci ha
veramente sorpreso e in qualche modo ha
sgretolato con l'idea di homo sapiens è
all'apice del mondo e c'è invece fatto
riscoprire vulnerabili una specie
fragile quindi alla luce di tutto questo
scenario drammatico
c'è una buona notizia infatti oggi
abbiamo una seconda possibilità è giunto
il momento di cambiare la nostra visione
e di assumere una prospettiva
biocentrica che ci permetta di ricreare
un rapporto armonico con le altre specie
animali e con tutta la natura fino a
questi decenni il nostro rapporto con la
natura è stato tossico
abbiamo inquinato abbiamo deforestato
abbiamo consumato il suolo distrutto
habitat di specie animali che oggi
finalmente abbiamo davvero una second
chance quindi a questo punto dovremmo
chiederci in che modo di animali
potrebbero tornarci utili se non altro
come abbiamo visto in questi casi noi
umani non abbiamo inventato molto anzi
gli animali ci hanno veramente
anticipato con un grande efficacia e
quindi in questo momento forse potremmo
pensare che proprio gli animali
potrebbero insegnarci qualcosa anche
magari per gestire meglio un eventuale
prossima pandemia